I'ma just say this fast as I can I'm
Gonna Let You Go
if you change your attitude
change your altitude
but you have to start living your life
in expectation you have got to start
expecting great things to happen for you
in order for it to happen it is the law
of attraction it is real it is nothing
fake about it
if you live your life in expectations
that's what happens to you if you live
your life in despair
that's what happens to you if you say
all men are dogs you're gonna meet every
last one of them I'll never be rich you
won't
you won't
the moment
you change the frequency
that your Tower emits
the moment you change that frequency
different things come back to you I'm
telling you this how it works
that's exactly what you should be doing
is trying to figure out
who it is that you're trying to be
right and you aim at that and then you
use everything you learn as a means of
building that person that you want to be
and
and I really mean want to be I don't
mean should be even those things those
things are going to overlap and it's
important to distinguish between those
because that's partly and this is back
down to the micro routine analysis so if
I say well you're going to try to make
yourself more industrious okay number
one specify your damn goals because how
are you going to hit something if you
don't know what it is that isn't going
to happen and often people won't specify
their goals too because they don't like
to specify conditions for failure so if
you keep yourself all vague and foggy
which is real easy because that's just a
matter of not doing as well then you
don't know when you fail
and people might say well I really don't
want to know when I fail because that's
painful so I'll keep myself blind about
when I fail that's fine except you'll
fail all the time then you just won't
know it until you've failed so badly
that you're done and that can easily
happen by the time you're 40.
so so I would recommend that you don't
let that happen I always tell people
don't wait to be rich what is that
richness it's abundance it's Joy it's
happiness it's contribution it's getting
out of yourself
because as long as we're thinking about
oh my God I lost something or you did
something I have less love less respect
less money if I think lost less or
because you did something
or because I did something I'm never
gonna have what I want in my life lost
less than ever those three thought
patterns they're the source of all
suffering and the antidote see it for
what it really is no it's BS and find
something to appreciate
fundamentally it starts with making the
most important decision of your life
which is if I would ask me up until two
years ago I wouldn't say that's who you
spend time with who you love because who
you spend time with is who you become I
think it's a I think it's still one of
the most important decisions in life
but you can pick the right person and
still do things in your head and make
yourself miserable so you really have to
decide the most important decision is do
I want to be happy will I commit to
being happy more important than happy
sometimes you'd be so happy to smile so
much your face hurts right you need
variety am I committed to living in a
beautiful state even when it doesn't go
my way even when it rains on My Parade
even when my biggest fear shows up
because I can't control whether your
husband or wife will live or die or get
sick or leave you or get a divorce I
don't want any of that to happen to any
human being I hate suffering I do
anything I can help people not suffer
but I can't control that you can
there are people who've lost their arms
lost their sight there have been people
that have been through the most horrific
experiences in life and they found a way
to still be happy because they've made
the decision that life is too short to
suffer most people half of what they
thought today is the same things they
thought yesterday how about themselves
about their life about their business
that's why most people's life don't
change very much
but if you wake up
and you start realizing I'm living in a
home an emotional home I don't want you
can change it
see because everybody's got if you've
got a billion dollars check this out if
you're a billion dollars
but the habitual emotions you go back to
are frustrated and pissed off
then your life is called frustrated and
pissed off it doesn't matter how much
money you have
write this down please the quality of my
life is the quality of my habitual
emotions
the quality of my entire life is nothing
but the quality of my habitual emotions
whatever habits of emotion wherever my
emotional home is I will find a way to
get back there and until I change that
I'm gonna have a problem
how many of you see people in some part
of the world in my country for example
you'll see this in the Middle America
where there's certain places that have
Cyclones all the time or maybe down in
New Orleans or places where every few
years you get a huge storm that wipes
out everybody right on the coast there
but then two years later it happens
again they rebuild it happens again how
many have ever thought to yourself why
don't these people move
why don't they move guys
because it's what they're conditioned
they call that home I don't want to
leave my home it's what I know
it's easy to see when it's somebody else
and it's physical it's harder to see
when it's yourself and it's emotional
because we have an emotional home some
of you grew up in a really tough
environment I did too pretty brutal
environment very painful environment
part of I am who I am is because I
didn't want to suffer how to find
answers and because I suffered so much I
don't want you to ever suffer if I can
do anything about it I can't control it
but I can help massively
but it's only because I suffered so much
don't anybody else to
but think about it most people suffer
even when they're successful
listen
if you're successful and you're not
fulfilled
that's the ultimate failure
if you got people that love you and
you're not feeling joyous and alive
something's wrong let me show you this
we all live inside a bubble right
this is our world we go to church here
we work over here we go get our coffee
over here we go to this park over here
we usually go over here to you know hang
out with friends this is our favorite
Club this is our world this is our
favorite spot on the beach we all live
in this bubble what you got to do to get
the life that God wants you to have you
got to put more air in your bubble
you got to blow your bubble up expand
yourself take yourself out your comfort
zone do not live in your bubble put some
more air in your bubble if you stay in
your comfort zone that's where you will
fail
you will fail in your comfort zone
success is not a comfortable procedure
it is a very uncomfortable thing to
attempt so you got to get comfortable
being uncomfortable if you ever want to
be successful
start putting some pressure on put some
pressure on yourself
get out here and get about it look I
love to sugarcoat this thing for you I
love to tell you look you can go out
here and get rich do a couple of things
that ain't happening you gotta get real
doggish you gotta get downright funky if
you want to make it when you get in
certain States you think one thought
when you get another state you think
another thoughts like training the
channel and so what I really show people
in the book how to do is how to turn the
channel so that you're not suffering and
you're living in a beautiful state but
what does it take let's just quickly say
it number one it takes acknowledging
what your favorite flavor of suffering
is it worry is it stress is it anger is
it loneliness is it boredom is it
overwhelm and then noticing what are the
thoughts that trigger that and realizing
it doesn't matter how much money you
have
those thoughts can still make a
billionaire crazy and frustrated and
overwhelmed and so when I show people to
do is a process and how to let go of
those thoughts and we walk through that
in the book in detail but fundamentally
it starts with making the most important
decision of your life